[Musique]
bons baisers d'amsterdam et la carte
postale que des milliers de jeunes ont
envoyé à leurs parents cet été et les
parents ont réservé sur cette eau forte
de rendre en planté au bord de la mer la
ville aux cent canaux aux étroites
maison mais il faut se méfier des cartes
postales
non ces jeunes ne viennent pas d'admirer
les toiles de maîtres ni l'architecturé
du xviie siècle
s'ils sont amsterdam sais qu'ils
apprécient notre tradition hollandaise
la tolérance une tolérance qui était
pourtant bourgeoise mais aujourd'hui les
bourgeois hollandais regarde avec une
pointe de surprises tomber les tabous
sexuels dans les vitrines des sex-shops
et une jeunesse venue d'ailleurs qui
refusent leur société on se réfugie en
être à partir du moment où on a un
contact apprécié quand on veut n'importe
quelle drogue on peut la voir
[Musique]
sur le dame en plein centre de la ville
cela sent le haschich à plein nez il en
veut fumer rien de plus facile il suffit
de s'asseoir au milieu d'un groupe et
d'acheter sa dose celui qui vient de
vendre ces quelques grammes de haschich
n'est pas un trafiquant
c'est un consommateur il ne vend pas il
troque comme on échange des billes à
l'école dans la cour de récréation et
c'est lui-même qui prépare le joint la
cigarette de haschich
cette scène n'aurait pas pu être filmés
en france ce jeune fille leur de la
chine serait tombé sous le coup de la
loi
au même titre qu'un grand drogués à
l'héroïne ou à l'opium hollande en
revanche on n'autorise pas mais on
tolère que n'importe qui puisse
consommer 50 grammes de haschich par
semaine on pense ainsi dans les milieux
officiels supprimer l'attrait du fruit
défendu et les l'action de la police
contre les hippies et sur très tolérant
très tolérants ils demandent parfois le
papier est-ce que vous préféreriez
malgré tout la police ou un peu plus
sévère oui vous êtes sévère à question
d'un truc
si vous passez faire avec lui de laisser
ces garçons ont suffi
trois policiers seulement pour
surveiller la place du dam pages chaque
jour des milliers de jeunes voilà tout
c'est que les affaires sérieuses se
traite d'ailleurs les gros vendeurs les
vrais trafiquants de drogue ne sont pas
parmi les jeunes avec lesquels ils ont
des rapports difficiles
on raconte qu'ils ont attaqué des
hippies fonds récupérés de la drogue qui
leur avaient vendu
on dit aussi que la semaine dernière
trois jeunes filles sont mortes pour
avoir absorbé de la mort aux rats 4 à 6
ans vend des produits à l'esprit c'est
pourquoi trois jeunes français
rencontrés sur le dames n'ont fait
aucune difficulté pour nous aider à
approcher ces gros vendeurs regardez les
ils vont prendre contact avec deux
trafiquants sur un pont d'amsterdam
ils ont sur eux un micro émetteur et
nous allons pouvoir suivre leur
conversation
l'un des vendeurs est un détaillant
l'autre dans qu'ils au bureau voilà on
vous a vue sur le pont la de loin qu'est
ce que vous avez acheté
2h lâcheté du h4 comment ça se présente
ça se présente comme une petite barre
comme ça quelle qualité s
ça c'est du libanais noir ça tu lis pas
des noirs
ça vaut combien sa défense parce que les
noirs que faire devant cette situation
les hollandais répondent protéger les
jeunes des 30 80
comment qui vient ce n'est pas le moins
surprenant en donnant des informations
sur la drogue à la radio c'était une
émission aux personnes peuvent donner
des informations et peuvent parler
exprimer leurs idées et on donne des
informations sur le sur la drogue sur
les droits et on doit et on donne je
crois aussi tous les emery et prix
réprimer les prix de la drogue sur le
marché amsterdam ouais les courts de la
drogue
ce ne sont pas là priseur fichiers âge
épreuve non il n'ya pas une bouche n'est
pas une bourse enfin c'est comme si
c'était une bo ouais on peut dire chez
toi c'est important pour protéger les
les jeunes contre les trafiquants des
prix plus élevés
[Musique]